[Musique]
faux
l attriste une captivité
afp
son acquéreur
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui beaucoup
à
y'a plein de maison ici
mais elles sont toutes clip hot j'irais
bien voir cela la bague l'autre côté
d'or
on y va
il y à 40 ans la nuit d'halloween
michael myers a assassiné trois
personnes après cette horrible nuit
il retournait en hôpital psychiatrique
et il en est plus sorti
[Musique]
depuis cette nuit là supprimer tous les
soirs pour qu'ils s'évadent pourquoi
faire une chose pareille
pour lui faire la peau
[Musique]
depuis ça a eu un accident michael myers
s'est est jeune et il va retourner à
deauville c'est chez lui je dois
protéger ma famille
t'as pas de système de sécurité karen
faut que tu te fasses était maman mal
existe c'est pas pour rien si on est
censé avoir peur cette nuit là ça fait
longtemps que je me prépare pour cette
nuit et il ne faut surtout pas traîner
dans les rues ce soir c'est un tueur
mais séduit qui sera tuée cette nuit
joyeux halloween maker
[Musique]